a portion of this video was sponsored by
salesforce
this is the biggest most in-depth video
about bowling ever
how bowling balls are made the best way
to throw them maximize strikes how the
lanes are oiled what it takes to be a
pro and how this sport has continually
been reinvented for literally thousands
of years up to the present day
this is the science of bowling the most
popular participatory sport in the
united states
i'm super impressed with how that went
i'm even more impressed than you are
what is inside a bowling ball well i
sent this ball to creative electron to
get a 3d x-ray scan
and this
is the result what is that i always
expected bowling balls to be you know
perfect solid spheres but there's
something inside here and it's not
symmetric and it's not even centered in
the ball so i went to storm bowling one
of only 11 bowling ball manufacturers in
the world to find out how bowling balls
are made
yeah basically when we make bowling
balls we always start in the center and
the center part of the bowling ball is
the weight block and as you can see this
is an example of an asymmetrical shape
weight block so it's actually a
different shape about the x the y and
the z axes
the weight blocks are embedded in a core
of lightweight glass beads
that is so silky soft i feel like i have
not felt anything this soft
what's the difference in density between
this sort of filler material and this
core it's quite a bit about two and a
half to three times more dense in the
inner weight block than it is in the
core material
if you were to look for example at this
actual core number one it says 960 which
means that it weighs 9.60 pounds and
then the description here underneath
which is the zero three this indicates
what type of a weight block is inside of
it
what happens over here so this area
right here is our urethane area
so basically what we have are a number
of different tanks that are set up so
there's a chemical reaction that occurs
once it actually fills the mold and we
pour that cover stock material around
the core
it gets extremely hot in just a matter
of minutes
you go right down here she's actually
pouring the pin material inside the tops
of those pores so you can see for this
particular bowling ball it's a bright
orange type of a material and she's
actually filling that hole with that
plug material
we've got the lathe right here which is
where we take the balls that come out of
the molds and then actually they spin
almost 2000 rpms on top of there there's
the blades that come around
and it actually makes the balls
perfectly round
so they'll actually trim those up since
the balls are not symmetric they are
heavier on one side than the other and
you can see there are the last four or
five pumps of air where it actually
floats the air then it stops and pauses
that the ball has completely settled and
then basically a needle will come out
from the bottom part and all of a sudden
it'll shoot it up and it'll be where the
center of gravity is on the surface of
the ball
when it comes right off the lathe
right here it is extremely porous and
very very dull and there is a ton of
friction between the ball and the lane
at this point so every ball from right
here will be smoothed up it's just a
matter of how much it's going to be
smoothed up in order to get what is the
desired finish
but before they can use these balls they
have to be drilled but that is specific
to each bowler
how many balls are you making a day
we're making over 3000 balls in a day
now that come out of this plant right
here
wild
i found the bowling ball equivalent of
click bait
you won't believe your eyes
the mind bending hook
right yeah it's how you have to sell
your stuff i guess exactly yeah
but how did it come to be this way
well bowling seems to be an ancient game
archaeologists have found wall drawings
of a sport that looks like bowling in an
ancient egyptian tomb dating back 7 000
years
in germany bowling was used as a
religious ritual pins represented your
sins so you're a good christian if you
could knock them all down martin luther
himself was apparently a bowling fanatic
and fixed the number of pins at nine
when the game made its way over to
america nine pin bowling was banned
because it promoted gambling the legend
goes that people cleverly came up with
10 pin bowling to get around the law
whoa totally different game
today in the us nine pin bowling is only
played in texas because it was the one
state that didn't ban it instead
charging attacks
bowling lanes are about three and a half
feet wide and 60 feet long down to the
head pin i'm using imperial units here
because that's actually how they're
defined
the lane is made of 39 narrow boards
that bowlers number for reference they
used to be made of maple and pine wood
but these days most lanes are synthetic
and made of fine particles coated with
melamine resin
one game of bowling gives you 10 frames
with two throws per frame to try to
knock down all 10 pins
the highest score you can get in a game
without a strike is only 190 but strikes
allow you to double count your next two
throws so a perfect game with all
strikes gives you a score of 300
if you're anything like me the whole
game is just trying to throw the ball as
straight as you can down the middle of
the lane hit the head pin and try to
take as many other pins down with it as
possible do you want to give me any tips
or i've watched lebron boy you won't be
worse than him i you say that now
yeah
see that's what i would normally do and
i would normally be like reasonably
happy with a shot like that but for pro
bowlers like pete weber or chris barnes
the perfect game yes the game is
different
and not just because they are way better
than
[Applause]
i
me
right
hitting the head pin square on is not
the perfect strategy
if you hit the head pin square on going
straight you're unlikely to knock down
all the pins
you could end up with a split where the
ball goes through the middle or with the
ball deflecting off to one side after
hitting the head pin
chances for a strike are much higher if
the center of the ball hits the pins
just to one side of the head pin board
17 and a half
in which case the ball takes out the one
three five and nine pins which take out
the others
so we want the ball to hit the one pin
the three
the pin behind the one which is the five
pin and then the nine or the eight and
the nine you want the ball to hit all of
those pins yeah now the pins don't
always fall this way but the pin shape
helps
pins roll in circles like eggs which
help knock down the others
[Music]
[Applause]
but to have an over 90 chance of getting
a strike the center of the ball has to
hit with an error smaller than half a
board
needless to say throwing a ball 60 feet
straight at a target smaller than a dime
is a tough task especially to do it
consistently
luckily there is a better way
now if we look at the pins and as you
look at them from here from straight on
the spot between the head pin the one
that's in the center and the three pin
which is just right of that that gap's
pretty narrow
but as the ball hooks more
now we basically shift over and now that
space is considerably wider
if you can hit the pins not head on but
at an angle of 6 degrees you
dramatically increase your chances of
knocking them all down
now the margin for error is greater the
ball can be coming in anywhere from
board 17 to 18 and a half that is a
board and a half of room and that still
gives you greater than a 90 percent
chance of a strike
now six degrees may not sound like a lot
but it's actually extremely difficult to
hit the problem is if you wanted to
throw the ball straight at the pins and
hit them at six degrees you would have
to be bowling from three quarters over
on the next lane
and that is impossible what with the two
gutters in between and all so the
solution is you've got to curve the ball
on one lane
i feel like i have never spun a ball
is that
is that hard so if you got it under your
hand the ball's underneath and you're
trying to spin it yep that's basically
the motion that players use these days
this really became a big part of the
sport by accident
the wood gets beat up with the damage
from all the balls going into it and so
they basically created slip agents
lubricants much like oil on a car so
that the lanes didn't get damaged so
quickly
so the original idea was to protect the
wood the original idea was just to
protect the surface of the lane it was
not to manufacture anything from a
competitive scoring type environment but
applying oil to protect the wood meant
that balls no longer gripped the lane
and rolled without slipping down to the
pins instead they could skid
rotating not in their direction of
travel
now i've been to a lot of bowling alleys
before making this video and i noticed
it was a bit greasy but i always thought
that was just the nature of bowling
alleys like the stinky rental shoes i
didn't know they intentionally put oil
on the lanes vox has a great video
specifically about oil patterns
these days there are machines
specifically for applying oil to the
lanes
and then as proprietors went huh well
yeah it does make the balls good well if
i put more in the middle than the
outside well my bowlers bowl a little
bit better and they're happier and then
as technology advances like everything
does now we have 30 000 lane machines
that can put a specific amount of oil on
each board they work kind of like dot
matrix printers they can lay the oil on
with varying degrees of thickness across
the lane and extend the oil pattern
different distances
there are hundreds of different patterns
that can be used usually the oil extends
about two thirds the way down the lane
so to around 40 or 45 feet but there's
always a dry patch of wood before the
pins that increases the friction with
the ball getting it to start rolling
without slipping
and this leads to the three parts of any
pro bowler's
the skid
the hook
and the roll
when a bowler releases the ball it can
be going 20 miles an hour and spinning
at 500 rpm that's nearly 10 full
revolutions per second right-handers
typically throw the ball to the right on
the lane while spinning it to the left
during the skid phase the ball slides
down the lane spinning but not rolling
as it comes to the end of the oil the
friction increases and the ball
accelerates to the left
it hooks because of its spin
and the spin starts lining up with the
direction of travel leading to stage
three roll the ball is rolling without
slipping as it barrels into the pins
ideally as close to that 6 degree angle
as possible
like the ball starts on the left side of
the lane
goes straight across almost
right most then hooks like at the last
minute
rolls in there
so that's that's almost like a perfect
shot right like straight into the pocket
there
yeah that's where you want to hit the
pins yeah
my very first game is it was abc back
then american bowling congress i filled
out the application to bowling men's
league dad gave me the letter saying
that i could
and the first game i bowled was 300 and
they handed me a hundred dollars too and
it was like yeah making money now
actually my my first my sixth my ninth
my thirteenth seventeenth
twentieth were all three hundred games i
like seven or eight three hundredths of
my first year of nunsley how do you
explain that to shoot 300 you have to
get lucky somewhere along the line
like that
like that it came in hit the one three
five nine
and that that's what we call the perfect
shot
i mean you just keep hitting him
that's almost the identical shot
look at that that yell and the purple
they're almost exactly on top of each
other that one just goes a little
straight that one the purple one was
just a little bit higher on the head pin
but it still hit the one three and the
five and the nine
can't get much better
this type of throw is only possible
because of the oil if you try to throw a
ball the same way on an unoiled lane oh
no
it just doesn't work can i actually ask
you to bowl like you normally would but
on the dry lane
i know it's crazy i just want to see
what like a normal shot would look like
if there was no oil no oil it's going to
hit the lane and go in the left gutter
that's what i want to see all right
you're going to throw it just like it's
a regular lane yeah all right
[Music]
oh yeah there's no oil on the lane so
the ball can't
get down as soon as it hits the lane
it's going to start hooking you know
because if you do this
who's going to want to bowl on us so
they want the oil yeah we need the oil
if we didn't have oil this is what it
would be and nobody'd have fun
this this is not full and sucks we don't
want to do this
for pro bowlers the oil on the lane is a
key part of the game
wow hey
do you like look at the oil are you
trying to scope it out are you just kind
of guessing i usually don't look at the
oil i let my ball be the guide
you know i know some guys that are you
know they get down like this and they're
looking and it's like well
you know
they're seeing the same thing i do when
i sit down i go like that
nothing
i see absolutely nothing whether you can
see it or not figuring out the condition
of oil on the lane can make the
difference between a strike and a miss
as the game wears on the bowling balls
move the oil around pushing it further
down the lane and stripping it off the
most common paths
so players have to adjust to the
changing conditions some people say
left-handers have an advantage because
well right-handers aren't playing on
their side of the lane
at most bowling alleys they use a
pattern of oil that is thicker in the
middle and thinner out toward the edges
this is a forgiving layout because balls
that drift too far out start to hook
earlier while balls going straighter can
continue down the lane for longer before
making their turn into the pins but for
pro bowlers the oil conditions vary and
players have to adjust their games to
the conditions some people seem to think
that like league bowlers are better than
they are maybe because they say like oh
this league bowler can shoot 210 and i
just saw a pro shoot 210. that's why
they call it league because you bowl on
the same shot every week because each
week on tour i'm going on a different
condition not the same condition every
week we have like cheetah chameleon
scorpion shark
one more bear bear yeah but it's not
just the oil on the lanes that is
transformed bowling it's also the balls
themselves hard rubber bowling balls was
what i started with maybe mid 70s and
then the yellow dot the columbia yellow
dot which is a plastic ball and then
they came out with urethane bowling
balls i won a lot of titles with the
urethane stuff and then they come out
with the reactive resin bowling balls
reactive resin is just a modified
polyurethane with a more porous surface
which gives it more grip in the oil
it's the most popular surface or cover
stock for bowling balls today balls
started out as perfect symmetrically
weighted spheres and when you go to a
bowling alley the house balls there are
still just that but when you drill holes
in the ball you take some weight out of
one side so to rebalance it ball
manufacturers added a small pancake
weight on the same side as the holes but
then ball manufacturers got the idea
they could add different weights inside
the ball to improve their performance
you can have two balls that look
identical from the outside weigh exactly
the same amount and yet roll differently
if the mass is more concentrated around
the axis of rotation say you have a
dense cylinder inside the ball well then
it has a lower moment of inertia and
this means for the same amount of energy
input it will spin faster in bowling
they prefer to talk about an analogous
concept radius of gyration or rg
if you were to concentrate the entire
mass of the ball onto a hoop with the
same moment of inertia its radius would
be the radius of gyration
so smaller radius of gyration just means
lower moment of inertia
which translates into more rotation that
a bowler can get on the ball
some people at lower river i think well
it just spins faster like
that's kind of crazy and then
somebody finally did a study and
it turns out yeah it's like eight
percent you know for
every 0.05
and so depending on whichever it is it
can be fairly significant
an ability to spin the balls faster
gives a bowler the ability to hook the
ball more sharply further down the lane
giving them a better chance of achieving
that 6 degree entry angle what was
amazing for me to learn is that the
weight blocks in these balls aren't even
centered there's a heavy side and a
lighter side on purpose and you can find
and mark this side by letting the ball
spin freely on a cushion of air until it
comes to rest heavy side down
they showed me a great demonstration of
how the position of the center of
gravity can affect the movement of the
ball
when the center of mass is on the left
side of the ball it pulls in the same
direction as the spin helping the ball
hook to the left into the pins same
exact ball same numbers
just different
static imbalance basically but here is a
flipped bowling ball where the center of
mass is on the right
now the ball starts to hook into the
left but at the end something weird
happens no the center of mass pulls it
over to the right
this effect is only really noticeable
when the ball is thrown slowly
these days there are tons of different
weight blocks that go inside bowling
balls and they can be grouped into two
categories symmetric and asymmetric for
all these weight blocks the minimum
moment of inertia or in bowling terms
the smallest rg axis is identified by a
pin which is visible on the outside of
the ball
it will spin most easily about this axis
for the symmetric weight blocks the ball
doesn't change as you rotate it about
this axis so the maximum moment of
inertia is rotating about any axis that
passes through the equator of the ball
i certainly didn't expect bowling balls
to have asymmetric cores but it turns
out what look like perfect spheres
actually have three different principal
axes of rotation
minimum moment of inertia maximum moment
of inertia and intermediate moment of
inertia
so this right here is our dart code this
is one of our asymmetric balls it has a
rad4 core in it so this has a preferred
spin axis and what we're going to do now
is we're going to put it on the
determinator and show how it actually
will spin it and find it no matter how
we position it on there
so you spin them up on this machine
until they settle into the way they like
to spin what the bowlers call their
preferred spin axis or psa
but why would you want a ball to be an
asymmetric top well professional bowlers
drill their balls so that at launch the
axis of rotation is somewhere between
the minimum and maximum moment of
inertia and as a result as the ball goes
down the lane spinning it processes like
a gyroscope the axis of rotation rotates
around causing the point of contact
between the ball and the lane to change
this precession means that different
parts of the ball contact the lane
and you can see this when the ball comes
back by the spread out lines of oil on
the ball's surface
bowlers call this track flare and it's
desirable because it means once the ball
hits the unoiled part of the lane it
gets traction faster and hooks more
dramatically back to the pins
this is what asymmetric cores are used
for they have larger differences between
their moments of inertia in different
axes or what bowlers call rg
differential which makes the ball
precess
if you spin a ball around its minimum or
maximum moment of inertia it processes
less and there's much less flare meaning
oil builds up on one part of the ball
this reduces the friction over the dry
part of the lane so the ball hooks less
see the oil there very faintly but it's
pretty much next to the finger
right next to the thumb and it just
continues
to be right that way all the way around
the ball
but how important are each of these
factors in actually getting the best
shot will the us bowling congress or
usbc the governing body that sets all
rules and regulations for u.s bowling
they did a landmark study in 2008 trying
to tease out the most significant
factors that affect ball motion
in order to determine the impact of each
factor they had to make sure the throws
were identical so they turned to harry
at the time the most consistent bowler
in the world
he is a robot
bowling robots are designed to be able
to throw hundreds of identical shots in
fact the robot earl harry's successor in
2011 actually lost to chris barnes when
he debuted in part because his throws
were so consistent he wore away the oil
in a single part of the lane so his
shots hooked too much
the people managing him did their best
to adjust to the oil conditions
but few people are chris barnes
the usbc ball motion study used harry to
throw thousands of shots with different
bowling balls and they found that the
center of gravity affected the ball
motion relatively little around the same
level as environmental factors like room
temperature or humidity rg and rg
differential essentially the moment of
inertia and difference between maximum
and minimum moments of inertia that
affected the ball motion significantly
more but the factor that affected ball
motion the most was the surface of the
ball
the top five individual factors were the
amplitude of surface roughness meaning
the height of microscopic spikes on the
ball the coefficient of friction with an
oiled lane
the surface roughness by spacing that is
the distance between microscopic spikes
the coefficient of friction with a dry
lane and how quickly the ball surface
absorbs oil
now bowlers recognize just how important
the surface of their ball is they pay
close attention to what it's made of and
how it's finished rougher finishes give
the ball more traction in the oil and
get it to start hooking earlier this is
useful for long oil patterns and slower
axis rotation sometimes
maybe i'll go to a little more sanded
ball or a little more ball surface
to get it into a roll quicker for me
because they use a lot of oil these two
shots are thrown identically the only
difference is the ball on the left has a
rougher surface
rough surfaces act like winter tires
helping to dig into the oil and give the
ball traction they also act as badly as
winter tires on a clean road on a
totally dry lane they actually have less
friction because their rougher exteriors
mean that less surface area is touching
the lane
you can get many different levels of
smoothness up to a near mirror shine
this is better for short oil patterns to
prevent the ball hooking too much too
early
ultimately pro bowlers carry many
different balls to each competition i'm
not afraid to change balls in the middle
of a game if i go to a game and i've got
like eight spare eight spare eights
all right it's time to change balls yeah
so now i got to find the right ball to
get down the lane again and find the
pocket which usually i have a pretty
good idea so they select their ball a
little like a golfer selects their club
to suit the conditions
but does all this tech actually make
people better bowlers
well over the last 20 years average
scores have increased by more than 5
points
plus the number of perfect 300 games
bold per year per thousand bowlers has
increased dramatically since the 1980s
this graph shows the percent change year
over year
in 1976 soaker balls balls chemically
softened to absorb oil and hook more
were banned and there was a dip in
perfect games
but the same year a new rubber ball was
introduced the brunswick lt48 and more
300s were hit in the years that followed
in 1991 reactive resin balls were
introduced and there was another
significant jump
now obviously there were other
improvements in equipment and natural
variability but some of the big changes
do correlate with the introduction of
new ball technology
so yes the wild bowling ball
technologies out there especially
anything to do with surface
significantly affect ball motion and
your bowling game but ball motion is
likely minutely affected by hundreds of
other factors even the color of the ball
can have a small impact a usb-c study in
2016 found that different pigments
absorb oil at different rates
bowling is the sport of reinvention it
goes back to ancient egypt but has
transformed many times
now when you get up to throw a single
shot you have to think about the oil
pattern on the lane the stage of the
game and how the pattern has shifted the
weight block in your ball whether you
want symmetric or asymmetric which axis
you'll spin it about to affect
precession where the center of mass is
to pull the ball to the left the right
where the cover stock is made of and
whether it's rough or smooth all to make
a shot that skids hooks and rolls to the
pins between boards 17 and 18 and a half
at as close to a 6 degree angle as you
can muster
now do that again 12 times in a row and
you have a perfect game
hey this portion of the video was
sponsored by salesforce bowling may be
complicated but managing relationships
with your customers doesn't have to be
in our modern work from anywhere world
salesforce makes it easier for your
business to meet the needs of your
customers you can help them find answers
about your business by creating a help
center page you can also meet your
customers where they're at by connecting
your email phone and social channels you
probably spend a lot of time on your
website so make it work harder for you
by leveraging lead capture forms from
salesforce right on your site and you'll
be able to generate new business and
develop relationships with your
customers straight from your crm sending
out messages or special promos is easy
salesforce has a whole array of
personalization and message targeting
options so you can request a demo or get
started for just 25 per user per month
at salesforce.com veritasium i want to
thank salesforce for sponsoring this
portion of the video and i want to thank
you for watching